[Music]
hi I'm ROH tamiya Google developer
advocate joining me today is Dave ransom
director of customer reliability
engineering so Dave we all know that a
series are trained to imagine the worst
possible scenario and prepare for it are
there ever scenarios which you've come
across which you've made you want to
pinch yourself from a waking nightmare
see you know rado cats are the patron
saint of the internet we all know
there's so many videos but did you know
that sharks are the mortal enemy of the
internet they're like the grumpy old men
so we had this fiber cable once I I'm
going to interrupt you there actually
because if if you tell ever on the story
now they're not going to have any reason
to come to next there are lots of
reasons to come to next great technical
keynotes and other stories that frankly
make the shark story look like the least
interesting thing you've ever heard join
us it next and especially join us at the
59 a lounge we have dedicated for fre
and get off people to come here all the
wonderful wacky wild and just plain
weird stories of what it takes to run
production systems at web-scale look
forward to seeing you